had a great year of great first person
shooter campaigns that was tasty that
felt good this week I've set Lucien's
more yet another challenge this time in
one of the year's best first-person
shooters titanfall 2 we're gonna side
who is actually the best pilot by
running the gauntlet and whoever wins
out of their best three attempts wins
the giant a I filled robot prepare for
titanfall think then thoughts go okay
running on the walls is faster yeah
except for when you fall off oh wow it
just puts you back at the start
interesting okay jump jump and again
okay so I want okay only got ya okay I
want gonna miss you it's like this jump
on the wall you have to kill everyone I
can't remember you don't well that would
have been good to know before i start
the damn thing but yeah boy what I'm
gonna kill anyone once again I missed it
get rigged it's okay training run
haven't been playing for a couple weeks
been in the dishonored mindset being
assassinating fools is fine get up on
the wall it's faster that's okay one
minute okay hang on so get 12 second
time penalty if you don't kill everyone
okay nine out of 15 well I'm a hold of
my gun waited let's get ammo take two
where am i okay needs to be honest it I
understand I'm coming feet
yep no why can I not do that jump cool
what did I get them sure why not oh you
bet you build it Oh God oh come on oh my
god Otto Sprint's not turned on oh are
you sort of a [ __ ] I've played myself
ah right well I'm just an accountant
deliver what does prints or turn on but
whatever [ __ ] up time get up kill him we
missed it's fine it's fine slide to
victory 112 oh I only killed six of them
that's why okay think pilot thoughts
think its pilot thoughts okay it is it
chocolate grenade
okay Chuck another grenade slew too soon
doesn't matter fine pilot thoughts no no
don't blame myself like that crap hey go
it's fine fine the penalty of the end
that's getting me she's okay right I
need to stop jumping off the wall and
remain on the wall which is difficult
because all I want to do is jump off the
wall apparently okay go go get him okay
go right oh my god why why me why you
like this can't wait to tell that 56
hang on wait oh I got a trophy suck on
that [ __ ]
all right guys let's do this that's call
of duty in it standby for titanfall
knows that releasing pie time that's not
all they say oh my god see this is the
problem i have i'm good at the wall
running and stuff but i'm bad at
shooting i think i might just give up on
the shooting and hop out of done enough
to not bouncing enough come on buddy you
can do it no school gone wrong it's all
gone wrong it's all gone wrong every
single part of it has gone wrong I hate
this game I don't hate this game I love
this game oh my god that was awful I've
done it in 30 seconds before below 30
seconds alright was my first attempt
hang on dude I want to run it captain
lastimosa lost samosa captain lot of
samosa you can have that internet for
free enjoy it me me up all right ready
123 go switch weapons because I can
okay this is come on white boy Wow do
this one up already yes killed myself
brilliant captain lost some also is not
going to be proud of me
oh wow I hate this game it's fine i've
got one more attempt I'm good it's the
shooting I don't like shooting I hate
Ewing in these types of games when I'm
focused on doing like crazy wall running
I'm just focused on getting into it get
vibing with it and I got to pull out a
gun and shoot someone wait don't make me
do that I don't want to shoot you just
want to be cool wall running man you
know what I'm just going to be cool
water running man in this one I'm not
gonna shoot anyone I don't care about my
school look at me I'm cool wool running
man yeah look at this having so much fun
when I shooting anyone we're just seeing
cool slide don't worry about guys I'm
not here to hurt you I'm just cool wool
Ronnie man look at me War one you know
my cool yeah look at this look at them
they're happy they get to get home to
their kids don't gonna worry about being
shot by a man running on walls it's just
the cold war running man he's not here
to hurt you at all oh good show anybody
I hate it again c 41 seconds and it gave
me a penalty for being a pacifist I'm a
pacifist every game I player do minimal
killing this is your home loss and also
right
right attempt number one I've only ran
this thing once when I was visiting our
lovely American office I basically
played titanfall non-stop while which
was nice because it's it's an excellent
game we've had a great year of great
first person shooter campaigns that was
tasty that felt good schmucks easy peasy
when I when I did play a little bit a
few weeks ago I pretty much got into the
pattern of quick was never a me that
mobility was more important than
anything a school I miss that drum nope
I don't know why I'm even bothering that
guy I go get on the backswing slide in
51 seconds all right um what what's the
record for this like three something
oddly 25 seconds ago attempt number two
had different weapons right here hello
Gary reload the first thing first
attempt numero dos come on ghost let's
do this thing honestly don't know who's
doing it in twenty somethings oh
that's not going to help I think
controlling hit the table to grow and
Dualshock vibrations I need to not get
bogged down until everyone this pistol
my work actually yeah reloads nice and
fast exactly how are you how are you
alive pleased to be the rude I'm gonna
follow the path around this way it's
time oh go for the treat I've got them
all got them all I don't know if there's
a time bonus but I got them all 47
number two it's the floppy hair does it
um how I felt pretty good base
difficulty set too hard good yeah that's
me I've not been using my grenades
anything I felt pretty good at the
pistol machine gun combo I'm just gonna
run with pistol just pissed all this
time I don't need no big guns my little
pistol baby will see me through now go
see this guy's just go and get punched I
really need but it's just slide into
these
ah kick right to the brain cuz i think
if you get less than 15 you get a time
penalty but I mean okay I'm not exactly
been counting my kills this one feels
good though this could be the best one
yet I've no idea what the other guys did
I know tangent plane as a bunch so I
don't well I think I just ruin my run so
I'd say terms and playing as a bunch so
he might be my best me I'm just gonna go
for the end of it I don't feel good
about this run anymore doesn't even
ma'am 47 seconds my best time-saving
dodo if there's the best one yet though
I reckon Sam's got it that's time for to
buy map with that GG no re
you
[Music]